[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález este 3 de
diciembre es conmemorado el día
internacional de las personas con
discapacidad una jornada ideada para
crear conciencia sobre este tema a nivel
mundial este año la campaña a nivel
internacional precisamente es
participación y el liderazgo de las
personas con discapacidad agenda
desarrollo 2030 la idea es empoderar a
las personas que tienen alguna condición
de discapacidad para un desarrollo
inclusivo equitativo y sostenible pero
esto suena muy bien cuando lo estamos
diciendo cuando lo estamos mencionando
otra cosa es hacerlo es materializar lo
sobre todo en una sociedad y en una
región como la de américa latina en
donde hay tantas desigualdades donde hay
tantas deudas sociales y donde está
prácticamente todo por hacer no sólo en
nuestra región sino pues también en el
mundo entero hay muchísimos problemas en
cuanto a la desigualdad veamos algunas
de las cifras
la oms se ha indicado que el número de
personas en condición de discapacidad en
el mundo es superior a mil millones de
personas esto supone el 15 por ciento de
la población mundial este organismo
internacional afirmó también que en
américa latina cerca del 12.4 por ciento
de la población tiene algún tipo de
condición considerada como una
discapacidad
los países de américa latina han firmado
varios compromisos a nivel internacional
para ser más accesibles
incluyentes y también para ser más
tolerantes ha habido muchos esfuerzos
pero todavía la lucha es ardua y todavía
va a tomar mucho tiempo desarrollar los
programas que están en curso las
siguientes son las ciudades consideradas
más accesibles en américa latina en
donde reitero hay algunos avances pero
todavía está todo por hacer
entre ellas están buenos aires argentina
santiago en chile ciudad de mexico en
méxico medellín colombia montevideo la
capital de uruguay son paulo brazil río
de janeiro también en brasil- córdoba en
argentina san jose costa rica y finaliza
este top la ciudad de bogotá a la
capital de colombia
este año la conmemoración está marcada
también por la pandemia del cob y 19 de
acuerdo con la o ms son muy pocos los
países que están recogiendo información
que permita ver datos en detalle sobre
estos dos aspectos
es decir pandemia y discapacidad muy
pocos países establecieron planes de
respuesta al control del coronavirus
para personas que tienen alguna
condición de discapacidad muchos
quedaron expuestos a la enfermedad oa
las medidas que adoptaron éstas llevaron
a que se agravarán sus condiciones de
discapacidad y como consecuencia pues
resultó perjudicada a su salud un debate
de reflexión y de toma de conciencia es
lo que les vamos a proponer hoy aquí en
france24 y para analizar y conocer
detalles sobre esta problemática a nivel
internacional saludamos a andalucía
arellano ella es presidenta de la red
latinoamericana de personas con
discapacidad y sus familias y ya está en
la ciudad de quito la capital de ecuador
y también está con nosotros fernanda
santana ella es presidenta de la
asociación brasileña para la acción de
los derechos de las
zonas autistas ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de curitiba en el estado de
paraná en el sur de brasil les recuerdo
que ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar sus preguntas
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales se las recuerdo estamos en
facebook también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
bajo s
santi logo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 comenzamos y comienzo
entonces en este debate poniéndonos en
perspectiva cómo está la situación
andalucía en la ciudad de quito gracias
por estar con nosotros hoy aquí en el
debate de france 24 y cuál es el balance
como esta américa latina como están
progresando allí particularmente de
ecuador los programas que nos permitan
hacer que nuestras ciudades que nuestras
sociedades sean un poco más accesibles
incluyentes tolerantes
muy buenas noches con todos y todos
saludos desde quito ecuador- y muy
contenta de unirnos a este debate
quisiera primero resaltar que cuando
analizamos la situación de las personas
con discapacidad debemos siempre hablar
sobre qué tan garantizados están sus
derechos y estos derechos están
enmarcados en una normativa nacional e
internacional a nivel nacional ecuador
es uno de los países a nivel mundial más
garantista a los derechos de las
personas con discapacidad sin embargo a
la hora de ver traducida esta realidad
política en la educación en la garantía
de puestos de trabajo de la garantía de
un empleo digno de esa participación
plena y efectiva la población con
discapacidad todavía nos quedamos muy de
lejos de ver toda esa normativa cumplida
en la cotidianidad y sobre todo ver cómo
inclusive nuestra población que
mayoritariamente vive sumergida en la
pobreza y pobreza extrema que todavía no
puede salir de ese incidente
subdesarrollo o que no puede participar
en igualdad de condiciones como las
demás personas como los demás ciudadanos
de derecho de la población del ecuador y
la misma realidad pues también se
extiende a américa latina es una
realidad generalizada la desigualdad
porque no solamente hay desigualdad con
las personas que están en condición de
discapacidad sino que la sociedad
latinoamericana es una ciudad
completamente desigual así lo dicen los
indicadores de diferentes organismos
internacionales
quiero conocer ahora la opinión de
fernanda santana en curitiba en el sur
de brasil
hola fernanda gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24 y cuál es su
balance su perspectiva de la situación
de las personas que están en condición
de discapacidad y los programas que
impulsan los gobiernos de los diferentes
países
buenas noches
creo que lo que dice es sala vacía es
verdad en todos los países de américa
latina
en brasil podemos ver que si es claro
que la desigualdad es presente para
todos pero afectan más fuertemente a
algunos grupos y
ahora con la crisis del coffee 19
podemos ver muy claramente las bajeras
quien frente a las personas con
discapacidad
más fuertes que nunca
así
a nosotros nos impacta mucho muchísimo
las dificultades de acceso a la salud
de acceso a educación y al empleo
si más adelante vamos a estar hablando
de esos tres puntos que usted está
mencionando fernanda vemos que este día
para conmemorar el día internacional de
las personas que tienen alguna condición
de discapacidad sirve para hacer balance
sobre los programas que están avanzando
a nivel social y a nivel gubernamental
vemos que vienen trabajando se algunos
programas y algunos proyectos desde hace
muchos años pero la condición de
discapacidad siempre hace ver a las
personas como personas que están en
desventaja personas por las que debemos
sentir lástima personas que no tienen
las mismas oportunidades que nosotros
eso todavía nos falta cambiarlo porque
las personas que están en condición de
discapacidad no están en desventaja es
un entorno que es adverso a ellos pero
están en capacidad de hacer muchísimas
cosas andalucía
por supuesto y justamente en este día el
día internacional de las personas con
discapacidad recordamos y resaltamos que
las personas con discapacidad son
ciudadanos de pleno derecho y cuando
como tú mencionabas cuando desde los
mismos gobiernos y la sociedad en
general mira a las personas con
discapacidad como ciudadanos de menor
capacidad de menor valía e inclusive
utilizamos términos como el minusválido
el discapacitado o personas especiales o
inclusive personas con capacidades
diferentes y también utilizamos una
política asistencialista y que no
permite como también decía fernando que
esas barreras que impiden su plena
participación sean eliminadas porque la
inclusión de las personas con
discapacidad no depende de la persona
discapacidad ni de su capacidad
de la sociedad porque todos somos
responsables actores públicos y privados
porque se trata también de que en el
mundo podamos participar todos y todas
pero por sobre todas las cosas cuando
inclusive nada le han hecho algunas
organizaciones y muchas de las
fundaciones de levantar fondos
justamente con ese mensaje del pobrecito
no estamos pensando en que lo que
necesitamos es por ejemplo a los países
del sur global tal inversor desarrollo
salir de la pobreza pero como lo hacemos
el término desarrollo significa cambio
promoviendo un cambio desde nuestra
mente de ver a la persona con
discapacidad como un ser humano con
aquello que tiene el derecho a ser parte
de este mundo y participar al igual que
todos los demás tiene sueños tienen
metas se puede como inclusive en algunas
ocasiones nos han preguntado en mi caso
yo soy mamá de un joven con síndrome de
dawn que tiene 24 años me dicen es que a
lo mejor las personas casi no me dan se
pueden casar pues si decimos que son
ciudadanos de derechos pues pueden
cumplir sus sueños y pueden tener el
derecho como cualquier otro ciudad claro
que si son ciudadanos plenos con todos
los derechos que tienen las
constituciones de cada uno de los países
la siguiente pregunta también se la voy
a hacer a andalucía pero quiero conocer
primero la opinión de fernanda entonces
una de las causas que esté haciendo que
estos proyectos y que la sociedad
responda tan despacio a estos proyectos
que se están impulsando es tal vez
porque la estrategia no está siendo
exitosa porque precisamente lo que
tenemos que cambiar es nosotros como
sociedad cambiar esa perspectiva de
verlos como qué pensar qué lástima voy a
ayudar si no como son iguales que
cualquier ciudadano que hacen parte de
un grupo social y de un país y de un
estado y de una nación
tal vez la estrategia está fallando y
eso hace que que la sociedad se esté
demorando tanto en avanzar
es necesario que cambiamos sí
el modo de vivir
para una
un abordaje de derechos así yo soy mujer
con discapacidad soy autista
a mí es muy importante a conocer y
luchar por mis propios derechos
y ya ve en ese cambio no sólo no
solamente esperan de la sociedad pero
también pero en los gobiernos los
estados y las personas con discapacidad
a través de sus organizaciones
representativas tengan la oportunidad de
participación
cuando hablamos de políticas públicas de
leyes
dije q lamentación de todas las cosas
que nos afecten la vida y todo
andalucía la misma pregunta tal vez la
estrategia entonces está fallando
tenemos que empezar es por crear
conciencia en la sociedad antes de
empezar a crear programas que tal vez
están teniendo mucha demora para poderse
desarrollar y lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es concientizar nos como sociedad
claro es que porque estamos demorando
porque justamente pensamos que la
población con discapacidad no tiene está
igualdad de oportunidades y pensamos que
con que el gobierno asistencialista
entregue a lo mejor bonos ayudas
económicas con eso se libre de la
responsabilidad de garantizar un sistema
de educación inclusivo en donde todos
estudien por igual donde esté sentado el
niño sordo ciego junto al niño sin
discapacidad cuando los maestros estén
preparados para educar al niño con
autismo o al niño con síndrome de dawn
en igualdad de condiciones que cualquier
otro niño sin discapacidad cuando
pensemos que es responsabilidad del
estado de que todo el sistema público de
salud debe garantizar una atención de
calidad para toda la población que su
infraestructura debe ser accesible que
el mundo tiene que ser accesible para
las personas con discapacidad pero para
cualquier otro ciudadano
nos estamos demorando porque aquellas
políticas públicas se diseñan sin
consultar a las personas con
discapacidad esa frase que distinga el
movimiento y es el motor del movimiento
que dicen nada de nosotros sin nosotros
debe estar impregnada en cada decisión
política pública privada cuando hacemos
de este mundo y consensuamos como decía
fernando esa voz de las cosas con
discapacidad la agregamos a todo lo que
hacemos porque con las personas con
discapacidad este mundo va a ser mejor
entonces la clave es consultar a las
personas con discapacidad cuáles son sus
prioridades cuál es esa agenda política
social económica entonces garantizaremos
que todos los tenemos incluidos en
fernanda ya voy aa continuar con usted
voy a hacer la ronda a la inversa
andalucía entonces en américa latina'
haciendo balance cuales hay algún país
que esté liderando en cuanto a políticas
en cuanto a garantías de derechos para
la para las personas que tienen alguna
condición de discapacidad
que sea un ejemplo a seguir para la
región o simplemente la región está
completamente quedada si se compara por
ejemplo con europa o con algunos países
asiáticos
andalucía
bueno si decimos cual cual país
latinoamericano toma la delantera yo
creo que no podemos especificar un país
pero si podemos hablar que nuestra
américa latina los gobiernos están
liderando por ejemplo si si queremos
resaltar la accesibilidad en el
transporte público brasil nos lleva la
delantera si queremos hablar sobre un
sistema de educación inclusiva tenemos
buenos aprendizajes en argentina si
queremos resaltar en cuál de los países
latinoamericanos
los gobiernos se comprometen con la
entrega de ayudas técnicas de la
población con discapacidad es ecuador
si hablamos de aquel país en donde se
establecen inclusive oportunidades
dentro de educación superior inclusiva
tenemos buenas prácticas en mexico en
colombia también en argentina en chile
en brasil hay buenas prácticas de
educación inclusiva también en brasil
aunque hoy por hoy inclusive está el
gobierno quiere aporte anunciado ya
decreto de dar marcha atrás de la
educación inclusiva y nuevamente
invertir y apostar por la educación
especial entonces brasil era una buena
práctica ahora estamos muy preocupados
porque no deje de ser esa buena práctica
entonces resaltamos todos aquellos
esfuerzos que se están haciendo por el
turismo inclusivo en república
dominicana en colombia en ecuador
tenemos áreas en donde los gobiernos
están interesando por realmente impulsar
la inclusión no podemos decir que ningún
país está haciendo nada creo que américa
latina ha dado grandes avances desde el
2006 cuando ecuador también con ese
liderazgo que trajo el ejecútese de la
convención internacional sobre los
derechos de las personas con
discapacidad que hoy garantiza esa
normativa internacional para la
población con discapacidad en el mundo
entero después de américa latina' lo
hizo con esa pasión que tenemos los
latinos en aquel 2006 pero ahora que ya
te han transcurrido 14 años todavía ese
compromiso político
termina de ofrecer un mejoramiento de la
calidad de vida de las personas con
discapacidad en todas las áreas quizás
sólo nos estamos concentrando en una
pero aquí el pilar fundamental de la
educación es donde estamos abogando
porque esa educación inclusiva sea para
todos y todas y de calidad y es que las
deudas sociales en américa latina son
tan profundas hay tantas necesidades que
tal vez hay que priorizar en algunos
casos a otras luchas que tienen que
hacer las sociedades de nuestros países
porque las diferencias son son mucho más
complicadas si se compara con otros
países alrededor del mundo fernanda
usted lo comentaba usted es una mujer
brasileña autista desde su perspectiva
desde su vivencia como ha sido vivir en
un país latinoamericano con una
condición de discapacidad por esta lucha
de derechos y de condiciones
andalucía nos mencionaba que brasil
tiene algunos puntos en los que es líder
en la región cuál es su opinión al
respecto
creo que esa es una pregunta bastante
complicada porque tener brasil es un
país muy grande
tenemos situaciones muy diferentes muy
distintas en diferentes partes del país
así si para mí en mi ciudad encuentro
buenas oportunidades buenas
oportunidades tal vez otra persona con
la misma discapacidad que yo y otra
ciudad
tal vez ya no encuentre esas mis mismas
oportunidades así
eso depende depende del contexto de la
persona depende de clase social depende
de
la intersección con otras cuestiones a
personas con discapacidades que hacen
parte también de otras minorías sociales
siempre encuentran más dificultad más
desafíos más barreras
a que aquellas que
no lo hacen
yo me gustaría mucho de enfatizar esta
cuestión de la educación inclusiva
pienso que acá en brasil estamos todo el
tiempo en lucha estamos luchando estamos
buscando mejores condiciones estamos
especialmente ahora estamos haciendo un
gran esfuerzo para no tener nuestros
derechos sacados de nosotros
[Música]
pero esa es también las cosas que
hacemos con mucha esperanza de que
tendremos un futuro más inclusivo mañana
y en su caso particular fernanda en qué
momentos ha sentido usted que la lucha
se está perdiendo que usted dice que
usted se ve vulnerada usted ha tenido
acceso a educación ha tenido condiciones
distintas a otras personas como usted
mencionaba en el caso de un país con
diferencias sociales como brasil pero en
su caso particular ha vivido la
discriminación ha vivido el miedo de
pronto por personas del entorno en no
comprender su condición y su situación y
tal vez simplemente apartarse un poco y
quedarse callado sino y no acercarse
mucho con cómo ha sido su experiencia
personal
claro la discriminación es aún muy
fuerte en nuestra sociedad
así yo tuve momentos bastante difíciles
en qué
bien las bajeras se tornan más fuertes
una de las bajeras más importantes es
más presente más grave es la baja era
actitudinal la forma como las personas
nos tratan nos ven
es muy difícil pero
hay también que luchar contra eso a
través por ejemplo de la sensibilización
concientización
por esos días como hoy son muy
importantes para nosotros porque son
también días no solo de conmemoración
pero también de lucha y reafirmar esa
lucha a nivel internacional fernanda a
andalucía allí en ecuador esta fecha
como ya lo decía fernando es una fecha
de lucha es una fecha para poner en
evidencia y sobre la mesa el debate
político y social sobre este tema que lo
que estamos hablando hoy que sucedió hoy
en ecuador algún tipo de eventos algún
tipo porque sé que el marco de la
pandemia no hace fácil este tipo de
conmemoraciones pero ecuador como vivió
el día de hoy
bueno tenemos que resaltar que estamos
viviendo un tiempo de pandemia y por
tanto no es posible realizar actos
públicos
hemos tenido un sinnúmero de un ecuador
en la región y en el mundo un sinnúmero
de eventos es desde este día lunes han
sido transmitidos por reuniones un
conversatorio dos declaraciones que se
que se han posteado en las redes
sociales en ecuador o inclusive tuvimos
a la primera dama quien estuvo hablando
en una de las sesiones programadas en
naciones unidas
justamente difundiendo aquellos éxitos
logrados con la política pública
inclusiva del del gobierno ecuatoriano
pero las personas con discapacidad en
ecuador lastimosamente y por la pandemia
yo creo que lo que han estado haciendo
durante este este día es resaltando
aquellas inequidades desigualdades
aquella población que inclusive fue la
primera en ser despedida durante la
pandemia es quien está visibilizando esa
realidad y aquellos niños jóvenes
adultos que también están sin poder
conectarse a la internet porque no
tienen un dispositivo con el cual ni
siquiera pueden acceder por vivir en
lugares remotos como el caso de la
población indígena que no ha podido
conectarse entonces no nos han enviado a
través de nuestras redes también esos
comentarios esos aportes para que como
dice fernanda sigamos en la lucha y no
des neiges andalucía el dentro del lema
del día conmemorativo de este año y
parte de la agenda para el 2030 es la
participación el liderazgo darle más
protagonismo y participación a las
personas que tienen alguna condición de
discapacidad como podemos entonces
visualizar esto al 2030 cuáles son las
las metas los retos
lo que se tiene que hacer de aquí
tenemos 10 años para desarrollar muchos
aspectos nos falta muchísimo
el primer reto es empoderar a la
población con discapacidad desde el
movimiento latinoamericano por supuesto
empoderar a aquella población que según
la cepal al 2014 la cifra va en 70
millones de personas
empoderar a la persona con discapacidad
y empoderar a su familia sobre cómo
abogar por sus derechos y cómo
transformar esos derechos a la acción y
esta plataforma latinoamericana de lucha
que es la riada que representa a 19
países de américa latina a través de 56
organizaciones nacionales de iu para la
discapacidad
justamente arrancó el mes pasado una
capacitación virtual con aval académico
de la cátedra unesco formando a 80
mujeres con discapacidad 80 jóvenes con
discapacidad de nuestra región para
lograr llegar a esta agenda 2030 con
líderes activos empoderados y sobre todo
promoviendo esa participación en toda la
región no es fácil hablar del
empoderamiento cuando estás combatiendo
la pobreza cuando perdiste el empleo
cuando no te puedes educar en un aula en
igualdad de condiciones con otros niños
y niñas no puedes hablar de inclusión
tienes que
no tienes esa esa realidad con un
entorno en donde te permita llevar tu
día a día y como decía primeramente
cumplir tus sueños así que la gente 2030
aunque fue exitosa porque por primera
vez demos ejemplo de desarrollo
sostenible fue impregnada la convención
y traducido de sus derechos a la acción
nos resta todavía un camino en donde
nuestro principal interés es porque todo
lo que se implemente a través de la
agenda de 30 días con las personas con
discapacidad
fernanda y en la ciudad de curitiba en
el sur de brasil usted es presidente de
la asociación brasileña para la acción
por los derechos de las personas
autistas
y traigo a colación el tema que estaba
hablando a andalucía que es el
empoderamiento como trabajan ustedes el
empoderamiento porque es importante
decirle a las personas que tienen alguna
condición de discapacidad que también
pueden hacer las cosas que se puede
lograr y que tienen los mismos derechos
y las mismas capacidades que las que las
personas y que el entorno es el que
dificulta un poco las cosas
pero no es una tarea fácil qué es lo que
hemos estado discutiendo hoy en todo el
debate y también en qué momento usted se
empoderó
me impone muchísimo a través de las
organizaciones de la participación en
las asociaciones y del contacto con
otras personas con discapacidad a través
de entrenamientos y oportunidades de
estar en
en espacios
y que me voy sen y estuviesen
interesados en saber
que pienso que quiero
para donde pienso que debemos ir como
grupo
así pienso pienso que ese es un primer
paso
y después
es muy importante encontrar
oportunidades accesibles y que te
ofrezcan apoyo y condiciones para esa
participación e incluye inclusive
a través de materiales
comprensibles
accesibles en fácil lectura
cosas como tecnologías estiba
y comunicación alternativa también son
herramientas muy importantes para
incluir las personas en ese contexto de
participación en la vida política
pública y política importante es esa
apreciación fernanda me quedan pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa
andalucía la perspectiva de la o ms es
que las condiciones de discapacidad a
futuro van a aumentar precisamente por
problemas ambientales por las
condiciones que estamos presentando
nuestra sociedad muchos casos de
diabetes problemas cardíacos el ritmo de
vida vertiginoso que tenemos ahora como
entonces usted la perspectiva a futuro
desde donde estamos hoy
muy puntual por favor
desde el movimiento y yo debería
insistir en que todas las decisiones que
se tomen por y para las personas con
discapacidad sean con las personas con
discapacidad y por eso es que estamos
construyendo esta plataforma
latinoamericana fuerte para incidir
desde el gobierno local y el gobierno
nacional regional global para que en esa
construcción conjunta sobre todo ahora
luego de la pandemia en este receptivo
del mundo sea un monto inclusivo
conforme a las prioridades de la
población con discapacidad vemos con
mucho optimismo aunque las cifras nos
llevan a la desesperanza pero el
optimismo va desde ese empoderamiento de
las personas con discapacidad para poder
construir lo que los demás piensan
que debería ser una razón para que las
personas con discapacidades se aíslen
más hemos luchado por estos años para
obtener una convención que garantice es
el lugar
que le pertenece a la persona con
discapacidad en este mundo y aunque las
condiciones estén adversas nos creemos
capaces de seguir luchando juntos y
fernanda su perspectiva a futuro dadas
estas condiciones que mencionaba yo que
da a conocer la o ms a la organización
mundial de la salud
creo que tenemos que buscar en quebrar
las barreras y hacer una sociedad más
inclusiva
sean pocas o muchas las personas con
discapacidad todos nosotros somos
importantes
con un futuro más exclusivo una sociedad
más inclusiva más receptiva
los problemas serán
mucho menores que los que tenemos hoy
pues a mis invitadas del día de hoy
muchas gracias ana lucia arellano en la
ciudad de quito la capital de ecuador
muchas gracias por habernos acompañado
hoy y también a fernando santana en la
ciudad de curitiba en brasil gracias por
acompañarnos multiplicado fernanda para
la estupendamente portugués muy obligado
y obligado por parte de la conozco o sea
dulce o testimonio muy publicado muchas
gracias a ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios sus sugerencias y también
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales y pueden seguir también en la
programación de france 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]